Good afternoon, Canada.
I must tell you,
I took four years
of French in school.
The first time I attempted
to make a speech in French
I was laughed at
So that's as good as I can get.
No, no, I'm serious.
And thank you very, very much.
Speaker of the House of Commons.
Speaker of the Senate.
Member of the Parliament.
Thank you for the very kind. Welcome.
My wife and I.
Prime Minister Trudeau,
you were my first meeting
with a foreign leader
just one month after my presidency.
During the hardest days of COVID 19.
We had to make our visit virtual.
But since then
we've been all over the world
talking and
taking on some of the toughest issues
our nations have faced
in a very long time.
Well, thank you for your partnership.
And for your personal friendship.
I thank you very much for doing
so.
Are grateful for the
hospitality you and Sophie have shown us.
Ladies and gentlemen,
honored to have the opportunity
to uphold a tradition
carried out
by so many of my predecessors
in addressing
the hallowed halls
of the Canadian democracy.
Although this is a different hall
that you've done a hell of a job.
This is really beautiful.
It is really very beautiful.
This is, of course, in the space
The closeness of our relationship.
Americans and Canadians are two people,
two countries,
in my view, sharing one heart.
It's for personal connection.
No two nations on Earth are bound
by such close
ties friendship, family,
commerce and culture.
Our labor unions cross borders.
So do our sports leagues.
Baseball, basketball, hockey
facilities, hockey,
I have to say that except the Leafs
for you on
I'm sure you are
I'll tell you alive
They beat the fliers back in January.
That's why.
And if I didn't see that
I married a Philly girl,
if I didn't say that, I'd be sleeping
alone.
Fellas, I like it, but not that much.
It can be easy
to take a partnership between Canada
and the United States as a given
and but when you stop
and think about it, it's really a wonder.
5552 mile long border.
More than 8800 kilometers defined by
peaceful commerce,
trading relationships that measured
more than $2.5 billion a day.
Every day,
hundreds of thousands of people
cross the borders,
going to north and south to work
or just to visit, knowing
they'll find a warm
welcome on the other side of the border.
Americans
love Canadians, and that's not hyperbole.
It's a data driven fact.
Earlier this week,
the Gallup poll did a new poll showing
American opinions
on different countries in the world.
This is a fact.
Canada ranked at the very top.
88% favorable rating
among Americans
Up from 87 the year before.
I take credit for that one point
I suspect
every politician in this
this room would die
would do a hell of a lot
to get those kind of numbers
But there's a reason for it.
The same fundamental aspiration
reverberate across
both our nations
from the Atlantic to the Pacific.
To live in freedom,
not just freedom, to live in
freedom with dignity, with dignity,
to relentlessly pursue
the possibilities of tomorrow.
To leave, leave our children
and our grandchildren
a future that's better
because of our efforts.
The people in this room and similar
room in the United States.
President Kennedy said.
And when he spoke here in 1961
and I quote,
he said,
Ours is the unity of equal
and independent nations
quote tenants of the same continent.
Heirs of the same legacy
and fully sovereign associates
in the same historic endeavor.
To preserve freedom for ourselves
and for all who wish it.
For all who wish it
through more than a century.
Of that historic endeavor, Canada,
the United States have had
each other's backs in war and in peace.
We have been the stronghold of liberty,
safeguard
for the fundamental freedoms
that give us our lives.
Literally, you give our lives meaning.
We have gladly stepped
into the responsibilities
of global leadership
because we understand
all that is at risk
for Canadians and Americans alike.
When freedom is under attack
anywhere in the world today.
Our destinies are intertwined,
and they're inseparable,
not because
of the inevitability of geography.
But because it's a choice,
a choice we've made again and again.
The United
States chooses to
link our future with Canada
because we know it will find
no better partner.
I mean it to the bottom of my heart.
No more reliable ally,
no more steady friend.
And today I say to you,
to all the people of Canada,
that you will always,
always be able to count
on the United States of America
a guarantee
together
Together we build a partnership that is
an incredible advantage.
To both our nations.
That doesn't mean we never disagree,
as any two countries
will do from time to time.
But when we disagree,
we solve our differences in friendship
and in good will,
because we both understand
our interests are fundamentally aligned
as we stand at this inflection point.
In history
that a professor
who once explained in a fashion point
as you're going down the highway
60 miles an hour
and you rapidly turn one direction
five degrees,
you never get back
on the same path again.
But but you're on a different course
where the decisions we make
in the coming years
will determine the course of our world
for decades to come.
It happens every five or six generations.
But we're at that point
Nothing gives me greater
confidence in the future
than knowing Connect Canada
and the United States
stand together still today.
I'd like to speak
to a little bit about the future,
if I may.
A future that's ours to seize.
You know,
I get criticized at home
sometimes for saying
that I used to always Barack Obama
for President Obama used to always kid me
because I'd always say to him
in our private meetings,
countries never more optimistic
than his president or his leaders.
Well,
I have never been more optimistic
in my life about the prospects.
I really mean this a bit. My heart.
We are so well for the future.
Build around our shared
responsibilities, prosperity, security,
shared values.
First,
it's a future build on shared prosperity.
We're going
to the United States, continue to anchor
the most competitive,
prosperous and resilient
economic region in the world.
That's a fact. That's just a fact.
Where our
supply chains are
secure and reliable from end to end,
because we're creating the value
at every step
right here in North America.
We're mining more critical minerals
to manufacture
and packaging
the most advanced semiconductors
in the world
to producing
electric vehicles and clean energy
technology together, a future
where we understand
that economic success is not in conflict,
the rights and dignity of workers
or meeting our responsibilities,
addressing the climate crisis.
But rather
those things depend on us doing that.
The pandemic has been
captured
Since becoming president,
I've been laser
focused on rebuilding the U.S.
economy from the bottom up
and the middle out.
Not a whole lot
trickled down
from the top down
at my dad's kitchen table.
And by the way, when the
when the middle class does
well the wealthy do very well.
No one gets hurt
The United States made historic
and to the chagrin,
some of our critics in the press
Bipartisan investments
in infrastructure,
in infrastructure, innovation
that are already bringing together,
delivering concrete benefits
to the American people.
And we
you know, as we implement
these legislative achievements,
there are enormous opportunities
for Canada and the United States to work
even closer
together to create good paying jobs
in both our countries.
The Inflation Reduction Act,
which I admit wasn't bipartisan,
but nonetheless,
all of a sudden, I'm finding
we have more adherence
represents a single, large commitment
in tackling climate in our history.
As a matter of fact,
the single largest investment
in all of human history.
And it's going to spur clean
energy investments all over the world
and explicitly, explicitly includes
tax credits for electric vehicles
assembled in Canada, recognizing
there's a simple reason
wrecking
recognizing how interconnected
our auto industries are
and our workers are.
I am the most pro-union president ever
America's ever had.
Hello.
And I speak to a hell
of a lot of Canadian union members.
Look, this the middle.
This is a model for future cooperation
with both our nations,
investing at home
to increase the strength
of our industrial bases,
making sure the products manufactured
in North America
are not only manufactured,
but they're the best in the world.
You know,
we're going to amplify
our shared commitment climate action
while growing our economies.
Like, I just stopped for
just a second and say, you know,
when I announced for president,
I was always known as one of those
kind of green Democrats.
And Republicans
used to be the same in my place.
Well, guess what?
I didn't announce
my my my my environmental plan,
and I was getting beat up while Biden
all of a sudden change you.
Well, the reason is
I brought all the unions together
and brought them into the White House.
Not a joke,
because they all said
we're going to lose our jobs.
And I pointed out.
Guess what?
Every single solitary initiative required
to deal with the environment
creates union jobs,
creates thousands of jobs,
thousands of jobs.
For example,
I met with the IBEW and pointed out
we're going to build
5500 electric charging stations.
Guess.
But also union workers.
So what for? 13. 18?
The standard for new electric vehicles
and charging stations.
So Americans and Canadians
can continue
to easily cross the border
without ever hitting a snag.
In their American
or Canadian built
automobiles, zero emission vehicles.
Or we're going to build
batteries and technology
to go into those vehicles together.
We've learned the hard way
during the pandemic,
the one we rely on
just in time supply chains, the circle
that circle the globe.
There are significant
significant vulnerabilities
to disruptions and delays,
and it drives up costs here at home,
both Canada and the United States.
But there's a better way
Canadians are blessed
with incredible natural resources.
Canada in particular,
has large quantities of critical minerals
that are essential
for our clean energy future,
for the world's clean energy future.
And I believe we have
an incredible opportunity
to work together.
So Canada
and the United States can source
and supply here in North America
everything we need for reliable
and resilient supply chains
Folks,
we folks
to make our critical mineral
supply chains the envy of the world.
The United States
is making funding available
on the Defense Production
Act to incentivize American
and Canadian companies
to responsibly mined
and process critical minerals
needed for electric vehicles
and stationary storage batteries.
We're also building
integrated supply chains
for semiconductors,
a critical computer chip
that I might note
was invented in America,
and then we lost control of it.
We're not only controlling,
we lost producing them
and the power
of so much of our daily lives.
The EIB play, the IBM plant in Beaumont,
Quebec, is the largest
semiconductor partnership,
packaging and testing facility
in North America.
Chips made in Vermont
chips made in Vermont
in upstate
New York are shipped to Beaumont
to be packaged in electronic components.
But now Beaumont is expanding
with the support
of the Canadian government.
There's going to be
a lot more work to do.
Thanks to the Bipartisan Chips
and Science Act
I signed into law last year,
companies are breaking ground
for new semiconductor plants
across the United States, representing
billions of dollars in new investments
in American high tech manufacturing.
$12 billion from Taiwan
semiconductor manufacturing company
in Arizona.
$20 billion and counting
for Intel on Ohio.
$100 billion in New York,
the single largest investment
of its kind ever in the world,
and just began to roll off
these new production lines in America.
A lot of them are going to be
coming to Canada to be packaged
and that's a lot of jobs, good
paying jobs. And today,
and today,
I'm also making
available through the Defense
Production Act, $50 million
to incentivize more U.S.
and Canadian companies
to invest in packaging semiconductors
and printed circuit boards.
Look,
that brings me to a second
pillar of our future
because of our shared prosperity
is deeply connected
to our shared security in the past.
In the past
years have proven that Canada,
the United States
are not
insulated from the challenge
and in fact, the rest of the world
the world needs Canada
and the United States working together
with our partners
around the world
to rally strong and effective
global action
Nowhere is that more obvious
than our united response
to Russia's brutal aggression
against Ukraine.
We've stood together
and stood together, defend
sovereignty to defend democracy
and freedom for ourselves
and all who wish it.
As I told
President Stilinski,
when I visited with in Kiev last month,
people all over the world
are with the brave people of Ukraine.
And you have to ask is,
aren't you amazed of the personal bravery
they're showing? It's incredible.
This is very hard
I know there's a large Ukrainian diaspora
here in Canada,
not just the lovely lady
we are all introduced to a moment ago
who feel the same way
Canada and the United States.
Together
with a coalition of 50 nations,
we jointly worked to put together
our making sure
that Ukraine can defend itself
We're supplying air
defense systems,
artillery systems, ammunition, armored
vehicles, tanks, and so much more.
Tens of billions of dollars so far
together with our G7
partners, are imposing
significant cost on Russia as well,
denying Russia
critical inputs to its war machine.
We're independently holding
Russia accountable
for the war crimes and crimes
against humanity
that Russia
has committed
and continues to commit as I speak today.
And Canada and America
alike
have opened their arms
to Ukrainian refugees.
Our people know
well the high price of freedom.
Our Peace Tower.
Your Peace Tower
stands testament
to the sacrifices
of more than 60,000 brave Canadians
who perished in World War One forever,
making this nation a champion of liberty.
In the words of Canadian poet
Lieutenant Colonel John McCreadie
still call to us from Flanders Field.
Echoing their charge through the ages.
And I quote it to you
from falling from failure
to me to you from failing hands.
We throw the torch
to you to hold it high.
So today, let's once more affirm
that we're going to keep
that torch of liberty burning brightly
to support the Australian people.
Will not waver
Putin was certain
he would have been able to break
naito by now.
He was certain of that
But guess what?
His lust for land and power
has failed us.
Four
Ukrainian people,
love of their country
is going to prevail.
In the face of President Putin's
aggression against Ukraine.
Canada
and the United States
are also making
clear our commitment to our NATO allies
will keep our alliance strong and united,
will defend
every inch of NATO's territory.
An attack against one
is an attack against all
And as we look forward
to the 75th anniversary of NATO
next year, Canada
and the United States share responses
military and a commitment
to make sure NATO's can deter any threat.
Defend against any aggression
from anyone.
That's the bedrock
of the security of both our nations.
Canada, the United States
are not only partners
in transatlantic security.
We are Pacific nations as well.
Earlier this month,
we held our first U.S.
Canadian Indo-Pacific dialog
to deepen our cooperation
in the vital region
to promote an Indo-Pacific
is that is free and open
and prosperous and secure.
We're also an Arctic nation.
We both recognize the critical importance
of this region to our collective security
and the interest of other nations
all of a sudden in the Arctic.
We're working in close coordination
to this to steward
and protect the north
in the northernmost reaches of our world,
where we are American nations
deeply invested in ensuring
that the Western Hemisphere
is peaceful,
prosperous, democratic and secure.
And that starts with our commitment
to defending our people
and our own sovereign territory.
Nor Ed is the only
bi national military
command in the world,
nor it is the only bi national military
command in the world.
Yet another way
in which our partnership is exceptional.
It is an incredible symbol of the faith
we have in one another
and the trust
we placed each other's capabilities
through.
Nor I will have a new next generation
over the horizon.
Radars
to enhance our early warning capacity,
upgraded undersea surveillance systems
modernize
infrastructure is necessary
to host the most advanced aircraft,
and I'm looking forward
to continue to work
in close partnership with Canada
as we deliver on these needs
so that our people
can continue to rest soundly
knowing nor Ed is in the watch
of
yours
We are also coordinating closely
to take on the human security challenges
throughout the region.
We're working in partnership
with our people,
the people of Haiti,
to try to find ways to provide
security, humanitarian assistance,
and help strengthen Haiti's stability.
We're tackling
the scourge of synthetic drugs
that are devastating Canada
and American communities,
particularly our young people.
Fentanyl is a killer the most, and almost
everyone knows someone
who has been affected by this.
Lost a child or lost a friend.
Canada and the United States
are working closely
with our partner in Mexico
to attack this problem at every stage.
From the precursor
chemicals shipped from overseas
to the powders to the pills,
to the traffickers
moving into all of our countries
and we all know synthetic opioid
epidemic has its roots around the globe,
not just here.
So today we're announcing a commitment
to build a new global coalition
of like minded countries
led by Canada and the United States
to tackle this crisis.
This is about public health
It's about
public health
It's about public health,
our economic futures,
our national security
We're also working together to address
the record levels of migration
in the hemisphere.
Los Angeles Declaration
on Migration and Protection,
which the United States
and Canada signed last June,
along with 19 other nations,
represents an integrated new approach
to the migration challenge,
which is a real
one that unites humane policies,
the most secure borders
and support people in the United States.
We're expanding
legal pathways for migration
to seek safety and humanitarian
and humanitarian basis,
while discouraging
unlawful migration
that feeds exploitation
and human trafficking.
So today, I applaud China for stepping up
excuse me.
I applaud Canada
I can tell what I'm thinking
about China.
I won't get into that yet.
I applaud
Canada stepping up with similar programs,
opening new legal pathways
for 1500 migrants to come to Canada
from countries in the Western Hemisphere.
At the same time,
the United States
and Canada
will work together to discourage
unlawful border crossings
and fully implement
and the updated
Safe Third Country Agreement
Finally, as we advance
our shared prosperity and security,
we must never lose
sight of our shared values
because our values literally the linchpin
holding everything else together.
Welcome refugees and seeking
asylum seekers
is a part of who Canadians
and Americans are In fact,
the United States recently
launched a new private
sponsorship program for refugees.
We call it Welcome Corps,
which draws
Canadian Canadians decades of leadership
in refugee resettlement,
where both countries
build upon the nation to nation
relationship
with Native Americans and First Nations.
We've
both been influenced
and strengthened
by the contributions
of a generation of immigrants.
We believe to our core
that every single person
deserves to live in dignity safety
and rise
as high as their dreams can carry them.
We strive to defend human rights,
to advance equality and gender equality
to pursue justice
and uphold the rule of law.
I want to note the outstanding work
Canada has done to build a coalition
of nearly 70 countries
endorsing the Declaration
Against Arbitrary Detention
and State-to-state Relations
It's not only a statement of values.
Our citizens are citizens,
not bargaining chips.
They're not diplomatic leverage.
They're human beings
with lives and families
that must be respected.
And I'm very glad to see the two Michaels
to Mike of Michael Schiavo and microphone
for safely back to their families
after more than 1000 days
1000 days with tensions
with my mother
she said God bless you both.
Thank you for joining us today.
And thank you
for having an opportunity
to meet you earlier.
You know, the incredible diversity
that defines each of our nations
is our strength.
And the Prime Minister Trudeau and I know
this is a belief that you and I share.
We both build administrations
that look like America
and look like Canada. I'm very proud
I'm very proud that
both of
us have cabinets that are 50% women
for the first time in history.
Even you don't agree,
guys that stand up
We took the lesson from you
because the bottom line is this.
We make it easier
for historically
underrepresented, underserved
communities to dream to create, succeed.
We build a better future
for all our people.
So let's continue the work
where there are no barriers.
Things look better.
There are barriers to equal opportunity.
We've got to tear them down.
Where inequity
stifles potential,
where we unleash
the full power of our people,
where injustice holds sway
Let's insist on justice being done.
Those are the shared values that imbue
all of our efforts are very democracy.
Our vitality and our vibrancy.
You know,
that's what it seems that drives us all.
Some places and some poor persons
are kind of forgetting
what the essence of democracy is.
We have
to reach
what allows
us to reach beyond the horizon.
Let me close with this
year.
After President
Kennedy spoke in Canada's parliament,
he delivered a famous speech
at Rice University,
issuing a challenge
for Americans to go to the moon.
In a decade's time.
You remember what he said?
You probably do
because we had to learn
that we were in school
because
we choose
to go to the moon in this decade
and do other things,
not because it's easy,
but because they are hard,
because that challenge is one
that we are willing to accept,
one that we're willing
unwilling to postpone, and one
which we will win.
That speech tapped into something deep
in America's character,
something powerful, a belief
that we can do big things
to hold a second.
Just think about it.
Turn on the television
the last two years,
whether it's in your country or mine,
after two years of covert
people beginning wonder,
can we still do big things, big things?
We sure and how can I have
that confidence
I believe in every fiber of my being.
That confidence can make
the most audacious dreams.
Reality.
The lesson
seven years
after Kennedy's
speech, the entire world watched humanity
left his first footprints
on those further shores.
It inspired a generation
that spurred
much of the technology advances
we now enriches our daily lives.
Today,
our world once more stands on the cusp
of breakthroughs and possibilities
that have never before
even been dreamt up.
In Canada
and the United States are leading
and will continue to lead the way
in just a few days.
Just a few days,
Max is going to announce
an international team of astronauts
who will crew
the Artemus two mission.
The first human voyage of the moon
since Apollo Mission ended
more than 50 years ago
will consist of three Americans
and one Canadian
We choose to return to the moon together.
Together we return to the moon.
And from there
we look forward to Mars
and to the limitless possibilities
alive, beyond.
And here on Earth,
our children
who watch that flight
are going to learn the names
of those new pioneers.
They'll be
the ones who carry us into the future.
We hope to build
the art of his generation.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're living in an age of possibilities.
Xi Jinping
asked me in the Tibetan plateau,
could I define America?
And I could have said the same thing
if you asked about Canada.
I said yes,
one word, and I made it one word.
Possibilities.
Nothing is beyond our capacity.
We can do anything
we have to never forget.
We must never doubt.
Our capacity can.
And the United States
can build
big things if we stand together,
hear them together, rise together.
We're going to write a future together,
I promise you.
God bless you all.
And may God protect our troops.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
You've been watching President Biden.
Biden addressed the Canadian parliament
in Ottawa.
The president fired up there at the end,
stressing the close relationship
between Canada
and the United States,
saying they are two countries
sharing one heart.
Among the biggest applause
lines, the president
talking about security
specifically in the context of Ukraine
and saying these two nations
are united
in support of NATO's
to defend against any threat.